du rythme des contacts du suspense les
finales de la coupe des yvelines de
futsal se sont déroulées ce dimanche au
complexe sportif fera pas il encourt
dérivé du fouta ont ce sport compte
aujourd'hui c'est ce que dans le
département
la discipline se joue à cinq contre cinq
sur un terrain de 25 mètres de long et
15 mètres de large est temps mort sont
rares le dégagement du gardien se font à
la main mais touche à fond au pied et à
chaque fois le gardien haut à la touche
il en 4 secondes pour jouer le ballon en
le posant sur la ligne au total plus
d'une centaine de joueurs se déplaçait
il encourt le match phare de la journée
oppose et des seniors masculins de
villepreux aux joueurs de carrière
grésillons dans cette rencontre capitale
les villes président n'ont pas fait de
détail en écrasant leurs adversaires à 7
à 3
petit papa s'avère un très bon niveau
après c'est vrai que nous pensons n'a
plus donné sur le terrain on a on a
montré qu'on allait tout faire pour
gagner et soulever ce trophée
ces deux trophées ils sont à nous
maintenant on a tous les efforts voilà
je pense que tout la partie a participé
à cette victoire
et voilà ça fait plaisir on a fêté ça
tous ensemble maintenant à la base on
était venu juste pour se faire plaisir
final on repart avec la première place
impeccable après avoir soulevé ce
trophée le fc villepôt tentera de sauver
sa saison
le club est actuellement au bord de la
relégation dans nos championnats de
football à onze de première division de
district et pourquoi pas viser dans les
prochaines années